you make a decision and you're like I
know this is gonna be difficult I know
it's not gonna be the easiest thing in
the world but I'm determined to do it
the more personal attachment you can
have to something the better all I want
to do is make stuff and if that's your
goal then you can do that whether
they're paying for your movies or not
need motivation watch the top 10 with
the leave nation
he's Jonah Hill and here's my take on
his top ten rows of success and joy okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
do things for the right reasons the only
decisions I've never regretted were ones
I made for impure reasons like to do a
movie because I thought it'd be a big
movie or you know like it'd be popular
or something instead of just really
feeling like it was the right thing to
do creatively so I just think every
decision you guys make should just be
completely from your heart and if you
wouldn't go if you you should only make
stuff you would want to show the whole
world forever you know and constantly
just go from your heart and don't have
anything else cloud your your judgment
you know purity I know it sounds like
really like straightforward and like
cliche but purity in your decisions just
your they should come from what you feel
all the time
rule number two be determined it's just
like anything you're gonna do yet you
know when I wanted to become an actor
and start making movies it was the same
kind of determination the same kind of
thing where you're like you make a
decision and you're like I know this is
gonna be difficult I know it's not gonna
be the easiest thing in the world but
I'm determined to do it and I really
care I'm really caring about this
decision so you just make it a priority
and you know when anyone's starting out
in any business or any sort of life
endeavor or any sort of relationship
you're starting out with the intention
to go all the way and to me it was just
a decision and I just made a commitment
to sticking to it rule number three have
passion I've been really lucky in my
career to make some films that I'm
really happy that I got to make and you
know Cyrus this movie I made I had to
play that part I wouldn't I would have
not I would have gone to the set and
ruined it if I would have like picketed
the film if I didn't get that part and
you know Moneyball and then this and
those are the ones that have worked out
for me the ones where I didn't you know
if I was up for them and I was really
excited about it
and someone else got it it was like oh I
could have maybe done that but with the
parts that I really care about like this
one which is doing I'm most proud of of
anyone ever played I really didn't think
another person could do it you know and
you have to have that passion I think in
order to give a really a performance
that you're happy with now I don't know
if he was kidding or not but Leonardo
said we did you come to him in Mexico we
did we met in Mexico we were both there
promoting films and I said can I meet
with you I literally pulled two Donnie
Azoff and I was like where are you I'm
coming to find you and I sat him to head
and I was like listen I I have to play
this part you know and I think he was
just so overwhelmed with my enthusiasm
for that hee hee hee he was the person
who called me when I got the part he was
the first phone call I got and he called
me and said like you know they just
asked me to make the approval you know
if I approved as a producer and I said
of course and let's go let's go do this
you know and I started crying like a
baby
and I also hadn't told my family and
friends I was up for the part because I
just so assumed I wasn't going to get it
so all the sudden I called like my
parents and my friends from high school
and I was like hey so I have some
interesting news I'm gonna be like the
second lead in this Martin Scorsese film
and they were all like okay man whatever
you're lying and just hung up the phone
on me because they're like well you
would have said something sooner if
they're you know but uh you know all in
all this is just this is the most
incredible experience I've ever had it's
the most excited I've ever been about a
film to show to people and friends and
other actors rule number four follow
your dreams
so you yourself you write you direct
your so should produce you produce your
executive produce you direct shorts
music videos is it an abundance of
creativity or energy or strategy or all
of it they're like oh asleep lack of
sleep I think it's just I like I said
this is just when I I wouldn't want to
do anything else in life besides make
stuff all I wanna do is make stuff
if that's your goal then you can do that
whether they're paying for your movies
or not you can go grab an iPhone and
leave and go out front here and like go
make a short with your friends and
that's what I would be doing if I wasn't
lucky enough to get to make movies and
stuff like that this business is so
weird that like if this isn't the only
thing you want to do in life then leave
the room and don't do it you know what I
mean but if it's the only thing you want
to do in life and you can't imagine
doing anything else then don't worry
about how much time it's taking it will
happen in whatever incarnation it's
supposed to happen in but you have to
just make stuff constantly and don't
worry about like making it make stuff
that sounded smart also if you want to
learn how to have more confidence check
on my 250 for confidence series it's
free the link is in the description
below my call time is at 7 then you back
your clock up for hours and then that's
when I get out and we have trouble that
oh my god if you want to give up did you
ever feel like that all the time you
thought all the time
and then you push through it you gotta
get rid of those haters in your mind
rule number 5 find mentors is there
anyone in director who you kind of
linked into is your idea of how the
director or is it just a combination of
all these different pretty people you
take things I think from everybody you
know you kind of see what would work for
you and what would in and honestly have
you know there's so many gifted people
but Bennett Bennett Miller who I've made
Moneyball with is a producer so he's
someone who's guiding me a lot and Spike
Jones and I wrote a play together
and our friends and he's helped me a lot
along the way you know very generously
and you know I just try and think of the
things that I thought were really great
about different directors that I worked
with and what I liked to hear as an
actor and you know try and give that to
the people that I'm working with most
filmmakers I've worked with like get
notes from other filmmakers or notes
from people who have done it I always
will ask like in life if I have like a
problem I'd call someone who's older
who's been through it
and done it like well in from my eyes so
you asked their advice right so I got to
imagine and I know for a fact that a lot
of times that filmmakers show their
movies in their scripts too you know
people they respect to get thoughts
because I don't think anyone's an island
I don't know maybe like the only person
I imagine who I've worked with who would
probably like that and I don't know at
all I'm just literally speculating as a
fan is Tarantino seems to like just
create these things and then you know
like he has these like magical
screenplays I don't know but I don't
know maybe he has people he leans on her
or or ask for advice I have no idea you
know rule number six show don't tell I
was aware of the book though willful
while she that Jordan Belfort wrote and
I right after Moneyball come out and I I
sat right in front of Martin Scorsese at
the Academy Awards I just said like
hello like that was it I didn't want to
I didn't I didn't want to he's my
favorite filmmaker of all time I
favorite artists of all time of any form
and and I got a call about a month later
that he was interested in meeting with
me about this this film and that I
wasn't gonna get the part but you know
that there are so many better actors
that want the job and I was just so
excited I was going to get the
opportunity to sit in a room with him
and even converse you know and I asked
if I could audition for him as opposed
to meet with him because I instead of
just saying hey I should play this part
you know it's like you're telling the
greatest director of all time like hey I
should play this part really you know of
course anyone would want to play this
part but I said let me you know let me
show you what I would do if I was given
this opportunity and and it was I'm
really glad I did that you know it's
always better to show something as
opposed to talking about it rule number
seven love what you do I'm curious
because so many actors who start off
being known for comedy you know really
struggle to transition to drama and it
seems to have happened pretty quickly on
your end and I know a lot of people cite
Moneyball but I actually think Cyrus was
may be the turning point were you even
actively seeking to change into drama
for me was never a change I don't know
about everyone in this room but I wanted
to be an actor
so I love films I love all different
kinds of films and and if you as a young
actor I was 18 years old if you get
asked to be in a film you're going to do
it you know what I mean it like like and
I love being funny and I love making
people laugh and that is a big part of
my personality as like if you were
friends with me or something you know
but it's not my whole ambition and it
wasn't my whole ambition as as an actor
so you know I was really young and I was
making these movies that were really
funny and people liked them and we kept
making them but when Superbad came out
you know I realized they were trying to
get me to make super bad over and over
again and I realized well I'm 23 years
old and what what if I'm lucky enough to
keep doing these over and over again
people are probably gonna get really
sick of seeing me do the same exact
thing over and over again as well as
it's not my whole ambition so I wasn't
like I need to find me like an AIDS
drama you know it wasn't like that
that's ridiculous but that's what a lot
of people do do they try to just go
completely the opposite way so for me I
have to be passionate about a character
that I'm playing I don't care if it's a
comedy or a drama I really need to
challenge myself to feel as if I'm
bringing everything I can to something
so after super bad I didn't do a movie
until Cyrus came along because I I
didn't want to do another big movie or
something that would be the same
repeating myself and I loved this film
was a small film and I got to act with
john c reilly Marissa Tomei who are two
of my favorite actors and then because
of Cyrus I got Moneyball on them because
of Moneyball got wolf of Wall Street so
to me it's never like I need to do this
to prove this to this you know it's like
I love acting and I love movies and I'm
I will do whatever I'm feeling
emotionally to express that as an actor
and that's like the only place my
choices come from it anyway rule number
eight make it personal the more personal
attachment you could have to something
the better I think that's what I found
when people have like the movies have
done or or this movie I'm about to
direct like why people of
to be a part of it is because the ends
up it's personal maybe people can feel
can feel that I know when a director
comes to me with something and it's
really personal to them I'm that's
infectious and I am more attracted to it
you know because it's something that I
know they'll work harder on because
there's real personal attachment to it
acting is becoming way more selective
for me and I'm spending you know I you
know writing and directing is becoming a
bigger part of my life especially this
year but you know I think I'm gonna try
and really act more selectively you know
and and and only really do things that
are that are really meaningful and
that's a goal you know that's just
always a goal rule number nine grow I
made a lot of movies really early on in
my career and I was lucky enough to meet
Judd Apatow and Seth Rogen those guys
and had a really great time making these
really funny movies but people imagine
it was like I think just whe they Judd
had made so many films there was only a
three year period it wasn't a very long
period of time it was it was only three
years in which I had made all those
films you know so you know it's been
interesting and then a big change in my
life came when when the Duplass brothers
brought me the script for Cyrus and that
kind of took my career in a very
different direction one that you were
looking for just kind of came along yeah
well after Superbad he'd come out you
know I got to this place which every
actor really dreams of which is where
you don't have to audition and and you
can be in a film and if the film will
get made you know and when all the
scripts were exactly the same is they
were just broad comedies and not as good
as super bad and so I knew that I wasn't
gonna keep doing that because I want to
grow as an actor I really wanted my
favorite films are Goodfellas and boogie
nights you know those are the films that
to be an actor you know so I want to try
and grow as an accurate and so just
before Cyrus you were 23 24 years old
and you would seriously decided I'm not
gonna take the wrong movie at this point
I'm not gonna just jump into work for
the sake of working it sounds like well
I said I have to make an effort to not
play the same character and to make sure
I'm growing as an actor and play
different kinds of characters and then I
did Cyrus and then Ben at Miller saw
Cyrus and cast me in Moneyball and then
Martin Scorsese saw Moneyball and cast
me and right wolf of Wall Street about
you being that self-aware at that young
and age it was an issue 'el it wasn't as
as contrived is that it wasn't like
you're talking about it more from like a
perception thing or as I'm talking about
it more from I'd like to play different
kinds of roles and it might continue to
do the same thing over and over again I
know I won't get that chance that's what
I looked at it from to me it's all about
like who I'm getting to play mm-hmm and
for what director you know that's been
the greatest joy of all of this stuff is
that I'm getting to work with the
directors I really look up to and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is have fun
ourselves up while ready
so they got us a massage person to give
us a massage so I'm gonna I figure
wedding luck
all right the sauce on the side of a
three-way dresses people can cars
driving lines so we're doing this right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just enjoying this
I know it's sharing it didn't feel good
now it's like this lady kind of sucks in
her jabs funny now but I gotta get in
there
now I've got two very special bonus cups
from Jonah on how to write letters and
challenge yourself that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go question number
one who are three mentors that you're
going to learn from this week number two
how can you bring more passion to the
work you're doing every day and number
three where can you show people instead
of telling people there's you know is so
cool and obviously super super genius
and he went it was it was right when
this film was coming out and I a lot of
good stuff was happening to me as a
result and he had called and asked to
meet with me and I was like no thanks I
literally almost jumped through the
phone and there was a there was a
another part that they were interested
in me for and then I wasn't able to do
it because I was doing another movie and
the schedules conflicted and the movie
was like wait you're the Tarantino movie
oh my gosh I'm doing this movie and not
able to do a Tarantino movie not against
the movie I was making just like oh my
gosh I'm not gonna be able to work with
one of my heroes because I'm not
available and so I was really a sad
because I missed this opportunity to
meet and to work with Quentin who's one
of my heroes and so they was were
already almost done shooting the movie
and and we were at summer of Sony which
is this thing like where all the Sony
movies do they go to Mexico and promote
the films internationally and Channing
and I were there for for change Damon
are there for 21 Jump Street and we got
to the hotel and all the Django
Unchained people were there and Amy
Pascal who's probably the most
innovative amazing person working in
green-lighting movies today she is a
genius and she emailed me and said come
up to this hotel room me and Quentin
want to talk to you and I went
they're here and I went out there and
they were like we still haven't the
other part is gone now obviously but we
still we have another scene that still
has not been shot yet and we want and I
want you to come do it and I was like
this is the coolest thing ever in the
world and all I wrote him a letter I
wrote a really long handwritten letter
about why it was like heartbreaking that
I didn't get to work with him and he
said it was because of the letter that
he kept me in mind and I told him like
yeah write people letters honestly
seriously though it's so nice it's it's
like the nicest thing whenever someone's
written me a letter I've always
remembered them so positively in my mind
I only I've said it a few times I only
want to play characters that are gonna
challenge me and make me scared because
that's when I feel I would be doing the
best work you know if I feel like okay
this is really something that's scary to
me then that's what I should be doing
you know it's just doing the same thing
and not getting any better
if you want to learn how to make it as
an actor check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there everybody told me not to be an
actor to this day I say that to people
who come up to me and say I'm thinking
of going into acting what do you think I
say absolutely not it's a terrible idea
don't do it